but he's I tell you what he is he's a
better person than both of them by far
the way he pees the ball about Phillips
better bastard and rodri
you think that rodri is a better park
pass to the ball than Phillips I'm going
okay
Phillips he's a bad person rodri 100
[Music]
are you laughing out I actually think
you did arms it's all you do arms don't
worry about what I do you look good
though you both look great yeah both
look really great
what's the plan well basically uh you
two are going to decide on a combined
Man City Liverpool first eleven and I am
basically going to be the judge so you
are going to have to convince me for
each position I promise there might be a
TV show in there there is a TV show
around for a bit um and then I felt like
it ran out of legs so
um but you know good to get that Dave
buns while you came
can you pick new players as well so can
I put Harland in
if you'd like to I mean I would what I
would say to you though is I'm judging
on this okay so you're gonna have to
have a pretty strong argument would you
mean that's a shame your football
knowledge is not really
the best but Okay so we've got something
in common so
uh
[Laughter]
we're starting at right back
wow that's your position
oh Trent or Walker
this is really a debate though what do
you mean is it of course
of course you can't just keep repeating
their names
there actually has to be some support
you know I don't know why this one is a
debate really I mean I get we're gonna
have a lot of comp like Midfield I'm
nervous that might I think you might
outnumber Us in Midfield Man City but in
terms of right back I thought you might
have just that you might just given me
that one but listen we'll chat about it
you're more consistent though Walker
or Trump I I think that this guy is
almost changing the game with his
Crossing and and his ability to set
goals up I just think he's numbers going
forward yeah but not defense and by the
way this is not a case I I think Carl
Walker is an incredible player you know
tremendous Pace I think maybe he's
starting to get a little bit older but
you didn't say that somebody's on the
show
I think you're the greatest you kept
saying that to him yeah this this one I
I think you've got to give this to me
well I can do both he can attack and
defend Carl can be suspect defensively
as well sometimes okay
um well I've heard your arguments and um
really great
I'm excited to him I think you're uh you
both put full great arguments and I like
you both and I respect you both as
colleagues and friends I'm gonna have to
I'm gonna have to run with Jamie and go
with Trent oh my Lord I I think deep
down you you know I just think yeah I
know who told you mate and I get that
and I like that I think Trent's one of
the best ever fullbacks but yeah we're
talking about
car Walker four Premier Leagues yeah
unbelievable player front three as a
whole guys
front free places
going there
I'll agree we can agree on that let's do
it okay so that's no judgment no no
Mary's got a little shout Mario's but
he's not he's not salary is he okay
really nice honestly it's really nice to
see you guys getting on do you know if
you really read this little team at the
moment and I'm happy I don't agree with
that one though but anyway okay Striker
what do you think Harland without doubt
no exactly
okay so right now so we Liverpool have
lost money
firmino's not getting the younger so I
do think that that's not really a debate
I think Harland has to go into that team
okay
let's get a little blue guy out and
stick him up there and shut your noise
you're right
yes but there's not a debate with that
with that one so this is going to be
difficult because you love Jack realist
don't you so much
you love him as well what
why do you like him so much because he's
just had a great summer I'm just
thinking you know he in our day he would
have fitted him perfectly because he's
had a heavy summer on it he's enjoyed
getting on it he's been out on it yeah
yeah
actually we might have brought you along
for the laughs you'd have been that sort
of guy sort of the nerd having to go to
the bar and Patrick yeah the wingman
we'll just send you in we send you over
you always need an ugly one didn't you
yeah I just I just think
it's been difficult for a minute left
side is a bit tougher on it what do you
think you manage it was because you can
play four different ways that's what
that's what means you play Fogo now or
do you put them in Midfield I mean de
bruyne is could we just put the broiler
down now just stop getting a debate
please really yeah
what are we saying you know it's done
but here guys some electric isn't it
this meeting of Mines it buzzing right
so hairs on the back of my neck yeah
right now how is this going to go when
is this going to end you're going to go
forward on the left side yeah see I'm
I'm thinking really more Diaz there and
I'll play maybe even falling in this
field Michael have you got responsible
no photos got to go here folder dog
realish has got to go there about what I
would pick photo
there
Diaz has done it for six months a big
fan of him but and we know you're a big
fan of fighting yeah but a huge fan
massive fan that's embarrassing yeah I
love you so beautiful I love you I've
not got a question it's just I just
think you're so magnificent it's just an
absolute Delight to what you do what you
do bro are you in rumsdale the other day
no let me tell you ramsdale I felt like
I held my own there dude A Little Bit
Stronger you want to put him in goal in
this team
you know what I was going to say though
I think podium
it's better on the right where he can
cut in on his left a little bit that and
that's where yeah he's not getting over
salad though isn't it that's what I'm
saying so I you can't then go well he's
a better left side just picking him he's
played on left side
but I look at foden up against if you're
looking at a debate for this team you go
foden or Salah on that side because fold
and cutting in that's when he scored his
good goals against it but he played left
as well he can but is he as good on the
left that's what I'm thinking I'll take
photo number DS right now I'm ready to
make a decision we're going fight him
yes
I don't
know it's a solid set of arguments and
even you yourself like oh yeah
yeah going forward sound a bit more
certain right this is where it gets
interesting okay hold in midfielder boys
rodri fabinio Calvin Phillips you forgot
about it and you have signed him no I
can't remember for this it's not in the
same bracket yet no not yet not yet not
yet it's unproven
that much money absolutely not that
ready yet 45 million
yeah yeah it's a slippers
isn't it isn't it
what are you talking about yeah but
that's you know it's a big deal from you
guys you rip off Merchants
no I won't put Phillips there yet I
don't think he's better than rodri and
certainly not better than fabinho
would you agree with that no I'm I'm I
like but I'll tell you what he is he's a
better person than both of them by far
the way he pees Phillips better faster
than rodri
is a better park pass to the Borden
Phillips I'm going okay
do you think he's a bad person Phillips
is a bad person rodrigue 100 all day
long you think that rodrig's a sort of
nice simple clutton type are you no are
you are you one are you thinking no you
must be winding me up one of the
cleanest Strikers of the ball that we've
produced in here maybe a 40-yard diag
I'm talking about them
like setting up attacks receiving it off
the left back and hitting it to the
right you're telling me that Roger could
do Roger's got that one that goes like
that Phillips goes through no no no
Phillips is my guy but he's not a better
person than right better possible better
pass to the ball listen we're gonna
break it down in terms of long passes
and the clean passage right now the up
out of your great knowledge is on right
back but don't come at me yeah
in England I'm telling you but I'm not
even going to pick him in this oh I'm
not going to pick him I'm going to go
who are you going to go I want to go
with fabina rodri's getting better and
better I think fabinho is a bit more
Mobile in terms of want to protect that
back our back four
yeah fabinio is a real deal so who are
we going for here Micah I would put
rodrigue the the way Man City play it
depends you want pastors you want passes
but then you want a brute in Midfield
by the way I love them both they're both
great players but I think in terms of
just his experience I think I would just
go with fabinia okay I've made my
decision on Gary
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay she's picked up bigger arms than me
I'm scared of you yeah you are okay so
you've said this is a no-brainer de
bruyne no this one no sorry
this is
the best midfielder in the world I think
at this moment in time without doubt
passing tackling
Vision everything all what you need is
without that it's a mess yeah and I
think in time you obviously had Vieira
skulls Keen
uh Lampard great Midfield plays I think
when by the time if he stays in the
Premier League for the rest of his
career I think we'll say he's the best
Premier League Midfield player ever okay
so that's an easy one yeah hope right
outside how are you going for Jeremy oh
this is difficult because
we've got our captain
Jordan Henderson Thiago who's just a
lovely footballer
you've got great New Field players as
well and that's why I always look at Man
City I'd hate to play against their
Midfield because Bernardo Silva on that
side as well Bernardo silver
I always felt this is where you might
dominate yeah
[Music]
I'm just saying I I I'm man City's
Midfield is Sensational I'd have put
fabino there but I think in terms of wig
this team attacking wisely de bruyne and
I you know and um Bernardo Silva would
be incredible but is he definitely
staying well that's a question because
by the time this comes out he might be
gone and we might have gone well Michael
you know what did they do they still put
this out yes he's really embarrassing
it's gonna be really awkward look at her
date almost immediately
that's the problem of doing this off
season the season lasted a couple of
weeks maybe if I'm saying by the time
this comes out it could look when's it
coming out
um the two weeks into the season 16th of
August okay well you've really
absolutely hamstrung I say mate
I think Thiago is incredible as well
yeah it's cool he's a beautiful
footballer but he's not he won't put him
ahead of Rodrick he's playing a bit
deeper no but I think he I I yeah you
can't you can't play him there he needs
to play in one of these positions and I
mean you could even play a two or one
couldn't you both yeah I think
yeah this is a hard one okay well I'm
ready to make a judgment Jamie uh I
thought you got some good arguments and
I like the way you move the counters
around so I'm gonna give this to tell go
Silva congratulations
nice okay Thiago that's interesting I
like it okay set and a half pairing guys
what are you going for
I think I'll be disappointed if we don't
think it's on the same lines here big
Virgil yeah without doubt that's a
no-brainer right yeah let's be sensible
because it's close and I'm going to say
Diaz
so I'm going to go with Virgil and Diaz
and I think we've got that is not far
off the perfect partnership I think they
complement each other so well can we
have a deal on that one I think my tips
being good though as well I'm not
feeling that at all together I'm feeling
I'm feeling it no I like Matty I mean I
think he's underrated I think he started
okay had the injuries but as you watch
him like last season arguably he was
better than Van Dyke in my opinion yeah
but I'll tell you if he went up he'd
look good next to Van Dyke
so I'm telling you if you took Virgil
out I think mattit would would I think I
think you'd find it difficult Diaz has
been good
but in a couple of times
later on in the season where you think
we'll get it over the edge
and he's not being dominant do you know
what I mean one one certainty I think
when we when we picked this team and we
knew we were gonna and this was
obviously rum's idea I think the one
certainty was was virtual though in the
whole okay yeah let's put let's put
Virgil street yeah let's put him in he's
one of the greats
easy okay
this is weird that I'm I'm actually
putting your player in a new one
you want to go and that's it I think my
tips
balance wise yeah I think diazzy's
probably got more but last season I
think Matic was class I'm going Diaz and
who are you going
if I had to pick if like proper yeah
that's one
I'd go with
deers but I think as a partnership the
complement each other so well done by
and mutton
okay
[Music]
why
are you going
he goes trying to balance it out
no it's not Jamie what how are you
writing romance's judging skills
generally you're just getting bullied
and there's a lot there
Yeah but I
should be the other way around because I
should want yeah a Liverpool player in
it but I just think that dude
no they don't need to I think you've
made a big a bad decision there but it's
fine okay I'm all right about it I'm
gonna be honest with you this isn't as
fun as I thought it was going to be
left back guys what are you thinking
oh
tough don't go there come on what do you
think Robertson get the red guy out what
can solo that's Robertson
well I love canseller as well but I just
think Robertson is
what he's done the last few years
incredible player what Asylum he's been
yeah I agree with that but cancelo some
of his part I was outside the foot
passes this is a tough last season can't
sell it was better in my opinion but he
played he played right back he played
left back I mean he could play anywhere
in this team couldn't he cancelo he's
such a good player if we're picking a
player where they actually play whereas
cancelo is so
playing these Freddy balls through here
you can do it that side as well hold up
what you're saying is because he can be
all over the pitch you don't want to put
in there no I do I just think Robertson
is a left back and this is you know
you've gone through a Liverpool before
Liverpool defensive I look a bit Ramesh
no cancelo cancel I've got to go
definitely
um
why are you going in the right pocket
for no reason I'm just sort of um
you can't go four Liverpool Defenders
you can't do that okay
because I just as the teams come
together I've sort of realized that you
know who he put there Diaz yeah okay
Diaz it's not like it because it looks
colorful no it's not about colors it's
just that I realize the balance of the
team and you know that's what judge
judgment's all about you know what I
mean so just sort of I think you made a
mistake here in Midfield as well Thiago
we didn't really even sell into you and
you picked him so like it was really a
little bit of well you guys can chat but
I guess you're gonna say what I want
like a proper helmet I'm gonna can I be
absolutely honest with you I find in
this whole setup quite intimidating
you know like if we do what would you do
in your comedy first eleven what YouTube
Pricks come up with
I mean I'm sitting there with two
experts I'm shooting myself
okay goalkeeper no that is that you need
to sort this out Rob why thiago's class
but Bernardo Silva needs to be in there
but either it's not about who's the best
is it about how it looks colorful
color-wise so just keep going
yes
all of a sudden pulled two points
first of all they're in my pockets I
won't pull them out my anus and secondly
you told me you said to me what you
didn't give an accident I'll go no but
that's not the point it's not why you
change it is it well I just sort of you
know I've got great judgment is knowing
when you might have made a mistake and I
actually I actually think I've probably
given the one one of the best examples
on this item the figures of showing
judgment if you would have kept another
red then there would be more Liverpool
players than Man City Man City have won
the league four times out of five so how
could there be more Liverpool players
makes no sense
yeah okay but that might be because it
makes no sense what go on yeah I'm
agreeing with what you do yeah you're
doing it quite aggressively if you don't
mind
doing it quite a scary way do you want
me okay let's go we'll agree on the
goalkeeper though yeah I think we will
we will but they're both great aren't
they we'll accept that but if this means
magnificent with his feet but the last
couple of months a couple of shots stops
it's not being at its best if you don't
think we go I think we'd agree on Alison
okay is one-on-one sales I just
magnificent so I mean I call it like
everyone in this team they all look
better when a virtual places don't they
no I agree with that yeah I'm going to
put Alison in but I'm going to be honest
with you I've listened to arguments
earlier on in this and I've put a thing
down and you've got quite aggressive
you've agreed on this right Alison yeah
okay but you might change your mind in a
second no listen this is it this is good
I'm happy with your change
I know it's offensive to anyone you know
even people that are going to watch this
they're going to go you know rodri or
fabino they're both brilliant players
aren't they I was a little bit offended
with you not you know accepting the
Philips Parts yeah I don't I don't I
don't agree with it no no that's all
right short passing I mean taking over
Roderick without rodri in man City's
Midfield they're not the same team I've
got to be honest I think that could be
one of the easiest jobs in football
playing there though I do really yeah
man City's team yeah I think he got
there's a lot of responsibility there
though yeah if you can really if you can
play
you're exposed you got the the fullbacks
go high like this if Audrey's a little
bit out of
yeah if you look at how many time
Rodney's on the half turn yeah and he
gets the ball off whoever that boom
boom
yeah I know but that's what I'm supposed
to say in terms of that position I think
they're there okay it's hard what are
you doing well I'm done mate
I don't know what we're still talking
because ramsdale's not in goals I'll
tell you what mate imagine what this
table look like we've got the Arsenal
involved oh my God oh my God
oh yeah Patrick Vieira Tony Evans sorry
happy with the team boys yeah at least
what team that would be it's a good team
yeah I wouldn't lose many games would it
Well Done guys cheers well done cheers
[Laughter]
by the way when Jack Greeley sees it
it's going to be fuming with you yeah
he's going to be devastating Calvin
Phillips no yeah no a raincoat is
unbelievable he's not a better person
than rodried now but you got really
angry about it Angry I just you know
honest honestly yeah honestly sorry
Calvin
right
this is Chelsea against an All-Stars of
the world
Angola kante makes it as a player I
think the being young is actually
probably just that just can't say as a
DM brother stop
you're smiling at you you couldn't even
say that with a straight face
for all these better than kante and I
think defensively there's not too much
of an agma but the two right even
cantado yeah